hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of Science
and Technology I see we have a whole
bunch of questions saved up here so let
me take a look at a few of these
um
this question here from M rudo do you
know about the history of the invention
of OCR optical character recognition not
a big expert on this but I can tell you
a little bit about what I know of that
um I think it was something that really
the first systems that worked I think
the 1950s and they were sort of using
early image processing and was sort of a
question of well what is an image well
it's you're kind of uh you know today we
might have a 10 megapixel image then we
might have an image that was you know at
most you know 5 or 10 pixels across and
the question was given
that you have sort of black and white
squares a small array of black and white
squares what will be the which character
does that correspond to and I think
people tried using cellular automata
that is local rules where you look at
the color of each cell and you determine
sort of an evolution based on the color
of each cell they also tried using early
neural Nets and in the end the early
neural Nets did okay and in fact by well
I think this really started to work in a
serious way in the um uh 1980s
um that was kind of the um uh the the
sort of early um
uh early you'll see all kinds of things
I I know you know Ray cutswell had some
kind of machine there were a number of
companies that had um
um had kinds of uh devices that were
sometimes in the read for the blind type
type category sometimes uh later there
were ones for reading things from checks
uh but that was the sort of different
branches there's the can you read a font
and then there's can you read
handwriting and things like the the nist
uh the the what was previously the
National Bureau of Standards now
um National Institute stands in the
technology made up this very widely used
machine learning data set of handwritten
digits that was I think done for people
who were interested in doing
um uh reading handwritten numbers on on
checks
and I think my impression of what
happened is that
there just were these
software packages
that sort of did reasonably successful
OCR how did they work inside people like
me didn't know until quite a long time
afterwards that they used neural Nets
they used sort of simple versions of
neural Nets without a lot of neurons
without a lot of layers and so on
um even I think perceptron type networks
are just one layer networks were able to
do something and I think that um uh gosh
I'm trying to remember the um
oh my gosh
uh I even know the person who did this
my gosh and I can't remember the name of
the company but there was a company
there were several companies that sort
of had kind of magic code that more or
less worked
um then there were kind of uh things
like Tesseract as an example of one that
was became sort of an open source thing
um their variety of these and even to
today there's sort of just been a
progressive Improvement in kind of these
trained neural nets for doing for doing
OCR
um it's kind of a it was an early
example of a place where things like
neural Nets actually worked and I think
that the you know the bigger challenge
was you know doing the digits they're
just 10 of them doing glasses the
alphabet there's maybe well 26 times two
or something with upper and lower case
then there's doing the ideograms for for
Chinese Japanese and so on that's
significantly more difficult
um and then there's uh you know I think
uh we we've built uh sort of OCR systems
that work across all the glyphs of
Unicode let's say uh for plain zero
Unicode that's like 65 000 glyphs that
was non-trivial to do and it's only
recently become I think feasible
um you can make a distinction between
you know 10 things or 30 things much
more easily than you can make a
distinction between a hundred thousand
things
let's see
um
Aaron asks about you talk about the
history of theories of extraterrestrial
life and the search for extraterrestrial
life
well gosh it's a um
uh
um that's a
it's a subject which is full of weird
stuff
so this idea that there might be other
sort of civilizations out there
I think people uh uh say Giordano Bruno
who came to a very sticky end was an
example of somebody who was talking
about sort of other other stars and uh
sort of human-like uh entities
associated with with other other stars
and so on and I think that was but that
as a kind of a a thing people routinely
talked about
um I'm not sure that that really emerged
I remember I I wrote about this in um uh
in um
and some notes and new kind of science
um the the the concept that there might
be sort of people living elsewhere was I
think reasonably widespread I mean or
there might be people like things
elsewhere I think Kepler for example I I
think was was made some comment about
how uh you know the the um uh the people
on the moon might hang out in the
shadows of this or that and make you
know have caves in this or that place so
that was kind of a thing and uh you know
one of the things that I suppose was
informing that was on the Earth
people had gone and done Voyages of
exploration and they'd come to the
Americas for example and they discovered
there are people there I mean it could
have been the case and that's actually
sort of an interesting thing it wasn't
the case that you know in in the old
world there might have been Homo sapiens
and in the new world there might have
been homo floriensis or something there
might have been a different subspecies
so to speak in a different part of the
world but the fact is that the mixing
time for our species is sort of short
enough on some time scale that that
wasn't the case so sort of the the
implicit assumption was wherever you go
they're going to be people there
um even on the moon for example
the concept that there might be sort of
other kinds of Critters I think was not
as uh
um as as prevalent
um I think that um uh By the time one
got to
oh sometime in the late 1800s
and one's got sort of a a generation of
Science Fiction of uh you know between
Jules Verne and H.G Wells and people
like this I think by that time it was
sort of pretty much well they're going
to be
they're going to be sort of things
living on Mars on the moon whatever else
uh to give some sense of confusion I
mean a famous example was around 1900
when radio had been discovered and
people were particularly Marconi sort of
early radio uh magnate so to speak had a
yacht going back and forth over the
across the Atlantic and you know in the
middle of the Atlantic Ocean it kind of
detected on his radio all kinds of funny
noises and so on
and he's like I don't know what this is
well Tesla picked up the same kind of
thing and Tesla said it must be
signaling from the Martians so at that
time that was kind of the the immediate
assumption was there are martians and
there'll be signaling and they'll be
using the highest Tech stuff we have
namely radio
and so that was a um
uh kind of an assumption of the time
um I think
then uh that sort of you know how did
that develop well
when it comes to life on other planets
when I was a kid for example in the
1960s and the first Landers were going
to Mars
there was a significant belief that they
would find Life on Mars and for example
one of the things that had been observed
is that there were
um kind of uh
um uh changes in in color on the surface
of Mars and people thought that was
vegetation that was growing and not over
the course of time now actually there
was another sort of episode with Mars a
person called the vocalers I think
um around
sometime late 1800s I think
was maybe maybe even early 1800s was
convinced
that
am I getting the wrong wrong person but
anyway uh well-known astronomer was
convinced that they were seeing uh
canals on Mars
and you know it so happened that that
was happening at a time when there was
lots of canal building on earth when
sort of canals were the highest Tech
thing going on on Earth and it's like
okay we're seeing these lines on Mars
there must be you know the Martians must
have an even much more elaborate uh you
know Canal system than we have I mean
one feature of talking about
extraterrestrial intelligence
extraterrestrial life
people often have the thought that
whatever we just managed to do that's
going to be the thing that um uh that is
going on all the time among those
extraterrestrials out there
now another example that I remember is
um
uh Gauss had this idea of let's signal
to the universe that there's lots of
clever mathematicians on the Earth
let's take a swath of Siberian forest
and cut it down in the shape that
corresponds to the Pythagorean sort of a
a you know a proof diagram for the
Pythagorean theorem and his kind of
assumption was that well the Martians
will see it and they'll uh it's kind of
a signal that there's intelligence here
on Earth so to speak
I think um but in any case by by as I
say even by the 1960s it was not at all
clear that Mars would be a sterile
planet
and maybe it isn't even totally clear
today but uh there was a big challenge
for example when the when the early Mars
Landers went to Mars This is must be uh
1960s
maybe even 1970 late 1960s beginning of
the 1970s the
it was a question of okay you landed on
Mars how do you tell if there's anything
alive here you know if somebody walks up
and says hi and starts waving at you
well then okay that's a thing but let's
say that they're microbes in the in
Martian soil how do you tell whether
there is live stuff there
and it wasn't very clear what the answer
to that was and it was um it was
something where uh people
kind of um they had a variety of
experiments one of the favorite
experiments was uh to essentially feed
sugar to the soil and see whether it
metabolized
so it's like feed it if there were
bacteria there then you would see
metabolism happening you know see what
happens there was also some strange
experiment that I remember from when I
was a kid about oxygen 18 versus Oxygen
16 different isotopes of oxygen and
seeing how they were relatively kind of
picked up by by the soil and I'm not
quite sure what that was supposed to
show but it was supposed to be something
that for whatever random reason seemed
to be a unique feature of life on Earth
now again to give a sense of a people's
view about about life elsewhere in the
universe
when the Apollo Astronauts
um uh went to uh went to the moon in
um the uh there was a whole protocol
that was I think set up by this guy
Joshua ludderberg who I met a couple of
times who was a microbiologist who was
also sort of an important um uh
government advisor and things like this
it was a protocol that said we better we
better quarantine these astronauts
coming back from the moon for 10 days
because they might bring Moon bugs back
and perhaps that had been fueled by
things like uh uh the um sort of H.G
Wells War of the Worlds story with the
Martians coming to Earth and then
eventually getting wiped out by microbes
on the earth and also perhaps fueled by
some history of uh uh sort of Europeans
having brought
diseases like smallpox and so on to the
new world but it was sort of interesting
that even in 1969 1970 there was um kind
of this idea that um uh that you know
the moon might have microbes on it was a
serious idea that with that um uh was
sort of people paid attention to
so anyway the the Mars Landers went to
Mars and there wasn't uh they didn't
find anything alive there and turns out
looked like that the changes over the
course of seasons on Mars were
associated with with dust storms not
with vegetation so that became sort of
not a thing
so then
well the other thing that happened was
radio astronomy and so radio astronomy
had been kind of developing in the 1950s
maybe even 40s with people like jansky
um and uh discovering the discovery that
there was lots of radio intensity from
the the center of our galaxy and things
like this
um and then sort of a big boost uh uh
when pulsars were discovered in 1968
sort of a big Discovery from um from
Radio astronomy at the moment when
pulsars were discovered the immediate
assumption was this must be beacons from
extraterrestrial intelligence but as a
matter of fact what one thing was sort
of interesting was that from what I
heard actually very close to the time I
even uh I was a kid then but I actually
ran into some of the people who were
involved in this stuff and it didn't
take long it took only a week or so
before they were pretty convinced oh it
must be you know something different a
neutron star or something there wasn't a
serious oh this might be
extraterrestrial intelligence it wasn't
it was wasn't sort of top of mind kind
of possibility for these uh kind of
precise pulses and so on that were
coming in
so
but I think around that time people were
sort of getting interested in let's
let's try and use
uh radio astronomy type techniques I
remember there were some people uh maybe
a person called coconi maybe a person oh
gosh what was his name my gosh
at the sky a few times
um he'd been I think that Chief
technology officer at HP at Hewlett
Packard
um and uh oh names on the tip of my
tongue but I can't remember it
um in any case there have been a sort of
small group of people somehow between
places like CERN and places like um uh
and Silicon Valley kind of uh pushing
for let's do things with radio astronomy
to try to detect extraterrestrials
um by the way another another piece of
this whole thing was you know Enrico
Fermi must have been in the 1950s uh
talking about what became the Fermi
Paradox of okay you know we're here on
Earth where are all the
extraterrestrials they must be out there
in the in the universe why aren't we
seeing them and all sorts of um uh the
um
um all sorts of kind of questions there
I might comment by the way I know the
the Soviet Union was also very um uh
very involved in um in questions about
uh sort of extraterrestrial goings-on
and things like Carter chef and these uh
different levels of civilization and so
on having achieved sort of different
energy signatures and so on in in um out
in in um uh in the universe
I think
what emerged with people like Frank
Drake and then Jill Tarter and so on was
sort of an attempted protocol for okay
uh uh sort of how do we how do we detect
things out in the universe how do we
detect sort of signs of intelligence out
in the universe
unfortunately as I say the the the the
mistake every time is to say whatever we
just got here on Earth is what must be
all over Across the Universe from all
those clever extraterrestrials and so at
the time it was kind of like we've got
radio signals we've got increasingly
powerful radio signals and so on radio
signals must be the thing and in
particular it must be narrow band radio
signals radio signals concentrated at a
particular frequency just like you know
you can you can turn the dial of a radio
or something they still have dials I'm
not sure if they do
um
to a particular carrier frequency that
will correspond to a particular radio
station and so on this idea that you
transmit radio energy by having this
kind of very concentrated frequency
band and that you amplify within that
frequency band well that's an idea but
it's only an idea that's relevant to a a
small period in in human history perhaps
50 years or so because increasingly with
you know 5G and spread Spectrum
Communications and so on it's no longer
the case that you're seeing this kind of
intense narrow band emission
but nevertheless back in the in the 60s
1960s when there was sort of a serious
effort to uh the beginnings of a serious
effort to kind of prospect for
extraterrestrial signals that was a time
when people said oh yeah it's going to
be you know a carrier signal uh
everybody's got to use carrier signals
let's go try and detect carrier signals
now one of the things that happened in
the US was there was a bunch of funding
through NASA for extraterrestrial
intelligence and there was this chap
called senator proxmeyer who went after
kind of government waste and uh
discovered this program looking for
extraterrestrials and kind of mocked it
and it lost funding from the government
for a long time
um and um that was and so then there was
sort of this private effort at funding
that became the seti Institute social
intelligence Institute which has gone
off and done things that have very
little to do with extraterrestrial
intelligence that's a different story
but um uh that was kind of so that was
kind of a a
um uh put a little bit of a a a a a
you know stopped some of what happened
in the U.S from from going on there
there were also other things like the
use of the Arecibo radio telescope to um
which sadly collapsed recently
um to send a signal out into the uh into
the universe there was a signal from us
that frankly if somebody could can
figure out what that signal is supposed
to be of
um it's very it's an impressive piece of
human decoding because it's it's a
rather obscure thing and people had
these sort of quotes clever ideas let's
make the array of let's make it into a
two-dimensional image and let's have it
be obvious there's two Dimensions by the
fact that it's a sequence of data that
repeats where the frequency of the
repeat is is a product of two primes
where you'd say well it's obvious that
you would take those two primes and you
would arrange them in an array with you
know a rectangular array with with the
lengths corresponding to those primes
it's maybe not as obvious as one thinks
but anyway so
that for a long time the the kind of the
emphasis was on this kind of narrow
bound frequency detection and what got
built was a lot of very special purpose
hardware for doing this I used to ask
why is the special purpose Hardware we
can do phosphoria transforms now we can
do what was when I was asking these
questions by 30 years ago or something
it was kind of the the very early days
of being able to think about software
radio and so on why are we doing all
this stuff in Hardware why are we
looking only for these very specific
narrowband signals I think a good answer
that I think um uh one of the people
maybe Jill Tata involved in this gave me
was which I thought was a as reasonable
an answer as one could give is well it's
something we can do there's plenty we
can't do but that's something we can do
you know if it turns out that the
signals from the cosmos are encrypted
like we or even encoded like we encode
the kind of the things and cell phone
channels well we you know we don't have
a good systematic way to decode those
unless we know what we're looking at and
so let's not do that yet
you know my own view of things which I
want perhaps go into in too much detail
here is that there's sort of
intelligence all over the universe the
issue is that it's just intelligence not
well aligned with human intelligence and
it's something where you know we can say
well the Pulsar is doing all these
complicated computational things as
sophisticated as the stuff going on in
human brains it just is the case that
what's happening in that your average
Pulsar isn't aligned with the kinds of
things that we recognize as going on in
human brains from from all of our
history and so on
but I think
uh it is interesting that the
uh you know science fiction has covered
the whole concept of you know first
contact with extraterrestrials and so on
has covered it quite extensively
and I think has quite informed the ways
that people think about this
scientifically
uh and I think the um this question of
um
uh
you know and nowadays
well I mean there's there's sort of the
whole astrobiology uh movement which is
kind of the modern version of uh uh of
sort of search for extraterrestrial life
and and a lot of attempts to say well
what is a signature you know if we
observe this molecule in the atmosphere
of some exoplanet what does it mean if
we observe you know there was a thing
recently we're observing I think
phosphines in the atmosphere of Venus
does that mean something about the fact
that that's a sort of a life like
signature and Venus well depends what
you mean by life if you have uh
um
uh if you've got um
uh the um
uh if if
um you know life on Earth all has a
common ancestor and all life on Earth
has RNA in it which is a very detailed
specific molecule and the question is if
you find life on Europa or something
um and it seems to be sort of singing
and dancing and it's a little millipede
that's walking around but it doesn't
have RNA in it then that's a yup we
found life and it doesn't have RNA in it
but if it's some weird little vesicle
that has some chemical processes going
on in it and we look at it and it's just
a weird little vesicle with chemical
processes we don't see RNA we probably
won't talk about it as being life even
if you know you can have it's rather
easy to have little oil drops for
example where you have one big oil drop
and it breaks into little oil drops and
maybe the old drops accumulate more oil
and So eventually they they break up
again and it kind of looks like it's a
self-reproducing oil drop but we don't
we say that's not a serious you know
version a life that doesn't have all of
the the apparatus that we associate with
life and in my own view now is a kind of
a defining feature of life is
essentially molecular scale
orchestration of things that in typical
chemical reactions and so on we just
have molecules bouncing around and
sometimes reacting with each other but
in living systems we have these
elaborate sort of paths and molecules
that Orient other molecules in certain
ways it's all very orchestrated and that
seems to be to me the unique thing about
life as that is more General than the
specifics of life on Earth with RNA and
so on
so a little bit of an outline there I
think it's it's a um
uh
it's a funny funny area
um that uh has had sort of
a whole series of of fiction getting
ahead of the fact and then people being
confused about the philosophy of the
fact so to speak of what does it mean
for you know to really have
extraterrestrial intelligence you know
if for example the pulsars were created
by this complicated process but we
didn't see sort of uh uh you know does
that mean that they are the leftover
beacons of some complex uh process of
this whole Giant star doing all its
things and they just left the Pulsar but
that's not intelligence
Etc et cetera et cetera
let's see
um
gosh four masks what do you think is the
most underrated undervalued scientist in
the last hundred years someone who has
contributed a great deal to society but
has largely gone unnoticed in the public
eye
that's a complicated question I mean
there are plenty of people who have
invented
things
that were potentially ahead of their
time
and
where those things did not become the
seeds that flowered into something
significant in in in science
but yet if you go back and look you'll
see yes they they got it they understood
the seed but perhaps they understood
that seed before the world was ready to
have that seed germinate
I mean one example of such a person is
uh Moses Sean Finkel inventor of
combinators
um in 1920
invented this thing that is a very clear
version of what we now think of as
universal computation the idea that
leads to software the sort of core idea
of computation so to speak he invented
that he wrote a paper about it it's a
perfectly clear paper nobody understood
it it was something even today
combinators are a more kind of a are
hard to understand but very clean
version of sort of core ideas about
symbolic computation and so on but Moses
Sean Finkel was 16 years before Alan
Turing and Turing machines and the kind
of the real sort of flow of of uh
interest in in computation even Alan
Turing was for a long time not sort of
widely recognized and you know when
people started building practical
computers they only then sort of thought
about oh there's this turing machine
thing that is sort of an idealization of
that
um I think that it is a complicated
thing because there can be ideas that
are before that time but are very
cleanly presented there can be ideas
that are before that time where you know
you go back and look at the paper and
you can say well now that I know how
this works I can fish this idea out of
that paper Maybe
um those are those are two different
things
and I think uh the um
the number of times when there are
things sort of suggested invented before
that time is is quite large and uh it is
I mean in my own life and times there
are plenty of things I've invented which
I I'm perfectly well aware are you know
a very long time before that time so to
speak and the challenge is to connect
them enough to what exists in the world
that people can actually engage with
them in the present time rather than
just oh yeah somebody discovered it in
100 years and they say that was really
cool back then it's more fun if you get
to see that Discovery so to speak
so I mean that there are uh there are
many examples of that in in different
domains I would say
in a domain
like mathematics
uh it's probably less
maybe happens a little less than some
other domains maybe because well I'm not
even sure that's true because because
mathematics sort of they're an infinite
number of theorems you could prove and
people kind of go from theorem we prove
to the next theorem we can prove and so
on and they build these chains and there
are you know the question of whether
people discover things and they discover
really cool stuff but nobody cares give
you a couple of examples
so back when ramanujan was around in the
1910s
he discovered all these cool things
about number Theory not that many people
cared about number Theory at that time
so many of those things sort of were
yeah they were slightly visible but they
were not very visible
another example uh trans-finite numbers
invented by Cantor in the 1870s 1880s
again it's like people knew about them
at the time but they didn't deeply
engage with other kinds of things and so
it was kind of almost like a lost
marooned Island in mathematics so to
speak
I think
in uh
uh in many other areas there have been
sort of discoveries made before that
time I mean whether it's Mendel sort of
talking about inheritance and uh nobody
really paying attention to that until
somewhat later uh people like oh I don't
know Ada Lovelace talking about the the
precursors of universal computation in
the 1840s lost for a very very long time
because there sort of wasn't a
continuous threat of history at that
time in these areas so you know I think
there's a there's a there's lots of
examples of this it's a it's a the way
in which science both has seated ideas
and turns into giant sort of trees of
activity those are sometimes somewhat
separate things and that leads to the
case where people sow the seeds and
nobody ever heard of that person sowing
the seed and then later it turns into a
giant tree I'm reminded of another one a
trap called shakard who um uh was a a
friend of Kepler's and who developed a
mechanical calculator for Kepler which
one could argue was sort of the first
computer of modern times the antacothera
device from Antiquity is our one example
of a completely lost kind of uh art from
Antiquity but but people won't have
heard of these very early computers
Jacquard Was Won then then Pascal who
was known for other things in maybe 1640
or something produced another uh kind of
mechanical calculator and these are
things which sort of eventually became
kind of eventually evolved into the kind
of the modern Notions of computers and
so on although it took a very long time
let's see
um
well here's a question a little bit more
uh in my own lifetime Des asks why were
Elite physicists and others reluctant to
embrace computers
so I I watched that happen so to speak
so this was um uh in the 1970s
uh
I will say that
when you looked at sort of the use of
computers there were a number of
physicists who absolutely embraced
computers for me it was one of them uh
you know Von Neumann who wasn't really a
physicist was it was more of a
mathematician was another
um there were absolutely physicists very
good physicists
for me a great example who absolutely
embraced computers
and um the uh and and managed to get
some mileage unfortunately firmly died
you know not long after sort of the
first electronic computers started to
become available to him
there was
a general feeling I think among
physicists that like with every field
every field has a methodology and if you
were a theoretical physicist you had
your books of tables you had your um uh
you had these kinds of things this was
the high art of theoretical physics
by the time you were programming a
computer that was something that was
delegated down to the people uh
sometimes literally in white coats
um who were sort of tending the actual
computer and so on I mean I say
literally in white coats because
mainframe computers had this very kind
of uh druidic kind of way of operating
where the the computer was hidden off in
some some back room and uh the users of
the computer at best would interact with
it by by putting Cod decks into you know
pigeonhole and getting back a printout
of it later I was excited back in 1977
when um when I worked at Argonne
National Lab in the US for a summer uh
and they actually let the the scientists
be you know in the computer room with
the computer right there it was uh you
know we trust the scientists enough to
know that they're not going to you know
press the button that makes the computer
self-destruct or whatever but anyway the
that was that was not a common case
I would say that um the general
perception was sort of using computers
was messy and complicated and wasn't
didn't relate to the high Art of Doing
theoretical physics
you know I myself started using
computers back in 1973 and uh I always
was very mystified by the fact that more
people weren't using them and uh the uh
it was true that there was a certain
degree of kind of um you know you had to
dive into the details a bit to know what
was going on you had to be a babysitter
of the computer it had been the case
that most of the time the people who had
built computer systems relevant for
physics for example it had to be those
people themselves using those systems
because things would go wrong enough
that it wasn't you know there wasn't a
well-encapsulated sort of nice user
interface kind of thing that would let
other people use the system it was more
like oh it kept on you know doing weird
stuff and you had to be the creator of
the system to know what was going on you
know when I built SMP back in 1979 uh
that was something which sort of began a
process of people being able to to use
it now remember there was another
phenomenon which was computer time was
expensive uh it had been the case that
there were mainframe computers where the
you know you would submit your job you
get the results back they were starting
to be timeshared computers
um there were even some on the Opera net
um
where the Dynamics were a bit different
and where there's no good reason
physicists couldn't have been just using
those all the time
but they weren't
and uh then in around 19 uh late 1970s
so-called mini computers which were
things like the vax computer which cost
like a quarter million dollars in those
days so probably a million dollars or so
today
um
were sort of Fairly powerful computers
that were sort of within the budget of a
single research group at least in a
place like the US
um and before that it had really been
the case that the computers were only in
the budget of a whole organization a
whole Lab a whole National Lab a whole
university things like this and so that
got to the point where for example
you know you want nobody was allocating
time on a vax computer nobody was saying
or most of the time they weren't nobody
was was saying oh you get from this time
to this time or your job is going to be
run at this time to this time it was
just like the computer is sitting there
and you can you know use it you can use
even Unix at that time there's starting
to be a thing and you would just use it
again it was utterly mysterious to me
why physicists were not using this but I
think it had to do with kind of the the
self-image and the fact that it was all
a bit messy and uh that you kind of had
to dive into the the kind of details and
and maybe also there was a certain oh
you're a programmer and programmers were
kind of Staff people who were sort of a
a several tiers down from the physicists
so to speak
um perhaps that was was part of what was
going on uh I think in um
I mean I've traced the history of quite
a few of these these kinds of things and
uh
yeah I think I think it's probably the
the the the the main conclusion is is
it's just that and and what really broke
it probably for physicists was was the
release of Mathematica in 1988 when the
it began immediately became the case
that the typical uh sort of theoretical
physicist could just read the
Mathematica book
um it was nice and short and uh get an
idea of how to do things and just do
them on their own computers and it just
worked and they didn't have to kind of
go and and find a babysitter for the
program and that was that was what
really sort of broke that down but it
wasn't until then that things got easy
enough for people to use now I have to
say I've seen the exact same pattern in
other places like for example uh in um
in automated theorem proving again
mostly it's been done by people who are
the creators of the systems and who did
babysitting you know when I did
something in year 2000 with only if
they're improving people who were sort
of the the the people in the field were
kind of shocked that some Outsider could
just come in and just use it and
discover something interesting that was
sort of unheard of and you know there's
been more work done now with proof
assistance and so on not automated
Theory improving has still not I believe
the result that I got in 2000 on the
simplest Axiom for Boolean algebra
Remains the only unexpected result ever
found by automated theorem proving as
opposed to things but once just
verifying something one one already
thought what was true you know I've seen
the same thing again a little bit in llm
science where you're kind of doing
things of starting to look at kind of
what can we conclude sort of
scientifically in a sort of physics
level about LMS and a certain reluctance
to sort of dive in and yes it's a little
bit messy with gpus and all those kinds
of things to go start exploring
different kinds of phenomena but that's
a place where hopefully this is a sport
will jump in but it's a place where
there's still some bit of resistance
like it's a little bit too complicated
and messy not helped by the fact that in
machine learning uh you know it is
steeped into the black magic engineering
detail which is sort of off-putting for
somebody who is used to something that's
more sort of basic science oriented it
makes it look like no I can't conclude
anything here it's all engineering
details
uh
RBS is commenting I saw an interview of
Ed Fred Kim where he explained how he
tried to teach Richard Feynman how to
use a Commodore pet computer you know I
have just been writing
a uh an obituary piece about Ed fredkin
which has been the most difficult
obituary piece I've ever written I mean
I knew ad for 40 years
and uh uh he had many different threads
going in his life he told many stories
uh many of them were deeply implausible
many of them turn out to have at least
kernels of Truth in them much more than
I expected and it's been just a horrible
uh although interesting activity last
few weeks untangling all of these kinds
of things I didn't talk about the the
Commodore pet story
um I knew about that
um I uh fireman had this um had this
Commodore pet computer that as a matter
of fact he he tried to program
um a cryptanalysis of rule 30 he and his
son Carl tried to program crypto
analysis of rule 30. this must be around
1984 or so
um but yes there was a there was some
terrible thing that happened there was a
first Commodore pet that somehow the
company that they were getting it from
somehow imploded and and the money was
lost but then a second one arrived and
uh and finally got into it he I don't
think he was that serious a user of it I
have to say I know uh fireman was much
more of a theoretical uh you know he had
been a human computer during the
Manhattan Project and so on he was great
at doing human computation
um he was not
did I ever see him actually use an
actual computer
I think not
I mean when I was working on SMP
he was involved in a bunch of design
meetings about SMP and he had many
opinions uh mostly about what one would
think of as ux so to speak of look I
have a mathematical expression and I can
move it around in this way and that way
and I need to be able to sort of point
at pieces and do this and that I think
that the reality of what was possible
computationally at that time and in
terms of uh sort of user interaction
didn't really align with what he thought
he wanted he was very keen on I'm trying
to remember this now
um
yeah he was very keen on these
particular tricks I remember him trying
to explain to me things about these
particular tricks for doing things like
integrals and so on that he had learned
over the course of many years and it's
like well that's very nice but those are
great if you're a human but if you're a
computer you can be do much more boring
industrial kinds of things you can just
make these very general expressions and
try and simplify them and so on and I
think he was much more into look I've
learned these particular Parts these
particular ways that I do computation as
a human and they weren't necessarily the
ones that a computer should use
uh
huh there's a quote from Fireman right
computer disease anybody who works with
computers knows about serious disease
apparently interferes completely with
work the trouble with computers is that
you play with them that's that's a funny
quote because the um
uh
you know when I was first working on
cellular automata and discovering that
these very simple programs could do very
very complicated things I was uh talking
to Dick Feynman about those kinds of
things and
um uh
I would say that um the thing that most
shocked him was that his assumption was
that anything about things I was
discovering I must have intuition that
they were things worth looking at and he
was relieved when he discovered that
actually no I I didn't have intuition
that this is what would happen I just
ran experiments to see what would happen
um I have to say I remember we were
working on quantum computers back in
must be 1982 I think
um and uh you know I realized that about
six months ago I found this these
printouts that I had from that piece of
work and I seem to have lost them again
it's very frustrating because I have a
good archiving system and search system
but these were just printouts of
solutions to the Schrodinger equation in
a spin chain and they weren't really
labeled they didn't have anything
written on them they were just you know
pictures and um maybe with some
handwritten uh sort of identifying
information but it didn't say you know
spin chain or anything like that and I
found these about six months ago and I
was looking for them again and I I can't
find them again but I will I hope
um but that was an example where of a
project that um uh dick Feynman and I
were trying to do where he was working
things out by hand and I was working
them out by computer I never understood
what he did by hand he never understood
what I did by computer and I'm not sure
we ever really managed to reach sort of
complete alignment on what the results
were although we sort of concluded
things about the difficulties of
measurement in the case of quantum
Computing but um that was a case where
very much it was um you know I was sort
of doing things by computer and he was
like a little bit suspicious about you
know how can you conclude this it's it's
you know what's actually going on in the
computer type thing
um I think uh
um actually I'm remembering now that um
his friend of mine Rick Field
um was
person with a lot of computing uh with
with dick Feynman on qcd and on the
formation of jets and qcd when you have
a high energy Quark or something
produced it kind of dresses itself up
with lots of other quarks and antiquarks
and gluons and so on
um to produce the particles that we
observe like ions and protons and so on
and uh dick Feynman had a whole bunch of
did a whole bunch of work which I think
he did partly as a as a social kind of
uh thing with where because he enjoyed
hanging out with with Rick Field but um
Rick did the programming for that and um
uh I was involved in that also and then
one of my less fine moments I I I didn't
try to apply I already knew quite a lot
about software design at that point and
I kind of didn't apply that to these
simulation programs for for particle
production which was a horrible mistake
because they were kind of messy and the
mess propagated itself for decades in in
political physics uh and would have been
would have been really great if that had
been more cleanly designed but in any
case it didn't happen that way but that
was another case where Feynman was sort
of uh working with other people who were
doing sort of the Computing side of it
um
the
uh memes is talking about Feynman and uh
his time at Los Alamos and personally
repairing calculators but he didn't have
computers they had mechanical
calculators they did not have modern
electronic computers that didn't happen
until after World War II
um the uh so uh yes I I do recall some
some stories about this
um and uh you know back
when when I was a kid
you know like places would have like the
school I was at had mechanical
calculators as long as well as I mean
the sort of portable version was slide
rules
um but if you wanted more sort of
precision you would use a a mechanical
calculator desk calculator
um actually when I got to Caltech in
um they still had in the sort of
theoretical physics area they still had
it was rather Charming actually they
still had these devices that were kind
of uh
um sort of built into the almost to the
furniture that were kind of um uh
calculators electronic
um that were pretty big objects and I I
have to say I didn't use one because by
that time pocket calculators existed
um but they were they were things I
don't know exactly when they were from I
think sometime in the 60s
um that were a sort of simple electronic
calculators that must have been made
with very early microprocessors this was
that must have been right in the couple
of years before 1972 1973 when pocket
calculators battery operated calculators
came into existence
um
the uh
let's see
um
question here
so the question from deaths about um
uh the early 60s in the Soviet Union and
proto-internet I do not know about that
I think it's very very unlikely
because
in um
in the Soviet Union
photocopiers were a horrible idea as far
as the government was concerned and you
know to operate a photocopier you had to
have a special license and actually I
was just remembering a bunch of stories
that Ed fredkin we mentioned before told
me and I I I was organized enough that I
did a piece of oral history with Ed
friedkin back in 2014 so I have the
transcript of that and quite a lot of
that was actually about the Soviet Union
and about his interactions with it over
computers but um one of the things that
he at least claimed there was that I and
one thing I know to be the case is that
photocopy is like printing presses in
the Soviet Union were things that were
very tightly controlled and you know
Ed's claim was you know a member of the
Communist Party had to read any document
that was going to be copied on the
photocopier so to speak and it had to be
sort of specifically licensed kind of
thing and so the idea that one would
have kind of a free-flowing sort of
uh flow of information I think was very
very unlikely that that was a thing uh
seriously considered there it may have
been a thing considered as part of the
uh the military sort of uh organization
you've got to remember in the U.S for
example and this was I was just kind of
uh relearning some of this stuff in
connection with this obituary I was
writing Fred fredkin
um one of the big projects was a thing
called The Sage project this is from the
mid-1950s uh it was um so the sage
project was an air defense system in the
US and the idea was the problem was well
let's say you've got Radars all over the
country you've got Radars that are
detecting you know a Soviet bomber has
just entered American airspace uh over
uh you know Montana or something like
that
um like I don't know my geography is
that border Canada I'm not sure but
anyway let's say North Dakota I think
that
let me not embarrass myself by getting
my American geography wrong Minnesota
that that's one that definitely is Is On
The Border
um the uh you know
a bomber has just entered the U.S there
okay we've got a radar somewhere there
how do we get Global control how do we
get a global picture of you know what's
what's attacking the US so to speak
and so there was this giant project
created to make a kind of coordinated
air defense system and the idea was at
that time to use telephone lines and to
have these local Radars to aggregate the
data through telephone lines and bring
it all to a big computer that happened
to be in Massachusetts at that time
um and sort of coordinate the the
signals from all these Radars with this
big computer and so kind of to give you
a sketch of of the times I mean at T was
going to provide the phone lines
provided the phone lines this project
happened this project was kind of the
most expensive uh sort of Technology
development project that had been to
date more expensive than Manhattan
project for example and um it was uh it
was a thing where so so ATT provided the
phone connections IBM provided the
computers it was the biggest computer
company Rand Corporation provided kind
of the programming side of things and
that was and then these things was all
sort of being aggregated together
and uh so
that was um in in the US sort of the
first form of I would say sort of
coordinated communication between
computer-like things was probably the
sage system
um and that uh uh was um I was back in
1956 when Ed friedkin learned to program
he did so as uh he was in the Air Force
and um uh ended up being one of the sort
of first cohort of the first hundred
programmers basically and the sage
project they estimated they needed
gazillions hundreds and hundreds of
programmers they were going to write a
hundred thousand lines of code and they
needed hundreds of programs they didn't
have those those programmers they had to
sort of
urgently train a bunch of people to be
programmers
um but uh
so you know from I suspect that Network
eventually emerged the Opera net
um and that was emerging like 19 but it
was 1960s by that time I mean it's worth
remembering that kind of that air
defense system
um became
oh you know it's in like the doctor
Strangelove movie there's a there's a
big sort of board showing you know
planes planes attacking I think that was
attacking Russia in that case but um uh
in um uh you know that the fact that you
could have a coordinated display of all
these things was far from trivial
um and uh uh the the concept that um and
that you know this eventually became the
thing that you know NORAD got
centralized in Cheyenne Mountain and so
on where it's kind of like you know dug
underneath the mountain to withstand
kind of nuclear attack I think I think
that I'm told the highest technology
part of that is the giant sort of spring
on which all the computers and so on are
are uh you know everything there the
facility is sort of on that so that even
if sort of there's a giant kind of
seismic event produced by all kinds of
uh uh atom bombs or whatever
um that it still doesn't disturb the
running computers I'm not sure that's so
much of an issue these days in the
original version of this it was all
vacuum tubes which would have been
deeply disturbed by having been sort of
Knocked around I mean it it used to I
don't even know these days uh you know
the typical laptop computer does not you
know withstands uh you know g-forces
quite well now I'm pretty sure it's
still the case that insofar as there are
any moving Parts like disk drives they
have accelerometers that retract the
heads for the disk drive if the thing
feels that it's falling and is about to
you know have a high acceleration event
but um I think uh
um
yeah I think actually Ed fredkin claims
to have been very deeply involved in the
kind of introduction of PCS into the
Soviet Union and this is
1984 type time scale a very bizarre
series of events I mean really quite
hard to make this stuff up but
essentially the
um uh Ed and other people were certainly
aware of the fact that
um
the presence of PCS would allow the
possibility of sort of information flow
outside of kind of government channels
and they saw that as being a thing that
was kind of a bring American values to
Russia type thing and and sort of a a uh
a way of injecting that into into the
Soviet Union and perhaps to the
detriment of the of the then system in
the Soviet Union
but uh
um there was kind of a uh Ed fredkin
ended up giving this talk at the Kremlin
um sort of extolling the virtues of PCS
and trying to get sort of enthusiasm
about having PCS in the Soviet Union
but the problem was the US had export
restrictions on PCS this thing called
cocom which was this export kind of
embargo on all sorts of technology and
so it wasn't obvious that one could get
you know PCS exported from the US to the
Soviet Union they were very detailed
constraints on exactly what attributes
the PC could have if it was exportable
and so on
but in something that I didn't really
know had happened even though I knew Ed
at the time when this was going on is
that there was this physicist Russian
physicist named Andre sakuroff Andre
sakuroff who um actually did a lot of
interesting work in things like
cosmology but had been involved with the
Soviet nuclear program was a major
figure in the Soviet nuclear program who
became kind of a Soviet dissident
and who was uh at that time uh in all
kinds of craziness and and sort of
internal Exile and Soviet Union and I
think was even sort of on hunger strike
and all kinds of terrible things
um and uh there was this was sort of
viewed as a humanitarian crisis of some
kind and uh the uh there was kind of a
lot of pressure for you know release
sakuroff type thing and so Ed kind of
conflated that with the story of PCS and
so on and was trying to get the Soviet
Union enthusiastic enough about getting
PCS then talk to the us about uh
having about using sort of PCS for
sakarov type deal and actually I found
in the Reagan Library uh there are
documents there's actually a whole file
about Ed fredkin and computers in the
USSR
and uh it's quite a um it's quite
interesting reading I mean it it got uh
you know there are there are things like
memos where George H.W bush was vice
president in those days
um was you know on the phone with this
person who was the uh the daughter of
sakuroth talking about you know Ed
fredkin going to the Soviet Union and
trying to convince them to have PCS and
whether that was something that would be
kind of a deal that the Soviet Union
would go for
um in that regard and uh I you know Ed
had its whole scheme where he would go
talk to Sakura and so on none of that
actually happened
um and the US kind of dragged its feet
on this um on approving the export
through what was then fredkin
Enterprises of PCS to Soviet Union but
some got exported and then lots more got
exported in subsequent years
um but so that was a uh you know that
was sort of the the introduction of PCS
into the into the Soviet Union
um was something that happened uh you
know it was it's kind of happened in
that rather bizarre way I have to say I
was was just remembering I visited the
Soviet Union in 1987
um and uh going to some conference
I was a very Soviet kind of conference
it was about
um
uh logic methodology and the philosophy
of science and it had you know in those
days you would go to
um
you go there and um they would have a
certain number of you know cosmonauts
uh with uh huge numbers of you know
wearing very large numbers of medals and
so on who would kind of sit on the stage
generally adding gravitas to the whole
Affair but typically not saying a word
and um the uh and they also would have
uh kind of the the flavor of the time
they would have all of the simultaneous
translations so you know sort of half
the audience will be wearing a headset
where there would be this um you know
translator in some Booth somewhere who
was translating uh between Russian and
English and so on and I think um the
uh perhaps you know in the flavor of the
time so to speak I you know when you
went to the Soviet Union in those days
everybody uh would get assigned some
kind of guide uh who was basically a
Handler
um to uh and and you could only go to a
very restricted set of places
um and uh my handler was a chap who um
uh I don't wonder if I knew his name I
wonder if I I don't know
um the uh who was some fairly young chap
spoke rather good English
um and uh although claimed to have never
been to the the us or any place that was
an indigenous English-speaking place
um and uh you know was just was telling
Tales of Woe about how how broken the
Soviet Union was I remember him saying
you know they had a refrigerator Factory
that for seven years had made all the
refrigerators were made and none of them
have ever worked and it was not a good
advertisement for the Communist system I
have to say but um uh you know and then
he had a whole tale of Woe about this
cocom uh export restriction thing and
how it was sort of destroying the the
potential of the Russian people and all
this kind of thing
um and uh uh but but it was just asking
me all these questions about the
American computer industry uh you know
which I was mostly kind of being a bit
vague about and uh eventually because I
wasn't really uh it was you know it's
one of these things where it's uh you
know sort of there's there's a
complicated line between what is
proprietary information uh I've never
had a security clearance so I don't have
to worry about that but um it's uh
definitely many questions being asked
that were uh was but I was pretty
involved in the in the computer industry
by that point and I knew a lot of stuff
that was sort of coming and um and not
really uh you know not not stuff you
could read in the newspapers yet
So eventually I I just like just asked
this chat well okay you're asking all
these questions tell me what do you
actually want to know
and and what he said was sort of
interesting it was in that in those
times the Soviet Union had successfully
cloned the Intel 8086 microprocessor and
they were wondering should they clone
other microprocessors in particular the
Motorola 68 000
um and uh the question was
um in you know maybe I went there a
couple years earlier than I'm saying
because that um it seems too late for
that question anyway never mind the um
but the question was maybe they were you
know just a bit delayed in asking that
question the question was kind of
um
was the Motorola 68000 worth cloning
going to be a lot of software
manufacturers who are going to produce
software for that and see the Playbook
had been that for example the Soviet
Union cloned the the IBM 360 Mainframe
computer and their idea was that they've
been all the software developed if they
could just clone the hardware same idea
as a lot of American computer companies
followed in subsequent years if they
could clone the hardware they wouldn't
have to rewrite the software
um the uh uh in um I mean Ed fredkin
actually tells a story of um told me a
story about
um being involved with that the project
was called Riyadh that was in the Soviet
Union for cloning the the IBM 360 that
apparently had had fallen upon hard
times and
um was eventually uh the whole thing was
was
um
um uh imploded and um uh with with uh
just that's a that's a separate story
but but
um uh the chap who was talking to me was
um was interested in you know should
they clone the 68 000 the Motorola 68
000 and then there was a whole kind of
tale of Woe associated with the fact
that the the 68 000 apparently had a
layer of epoxy on the surface of the
microprocessor that was hard to uh to
get through you know presumably on the
on the 1886 you've been able to
basically just get an electron
microscope or maybe even an microscope
and look at the the circuit pattern and
be able to sort of Clone the circuit
pattern but on the 68000 it had a layer
of oxy that made it hard to do that so
he said
um and uh he was convinced that that was
there because the US government was
trying to prevent Motorola from um uh
you know letting the Russians clone the
68 000 and so on and uh you know I said
I really doubt that that's the case I
think it is vastly more likely that it's
there so that Intel will not clone the
Motorola 68 000.
um and he had a very hard time believing
that that was a um uh it's just a
a kind of um commercial uh competition
like that was not a thing that was a a a
a you know the same kind of known thing
in in Soviet Union at that time so it
wasn't it was something that was hard to
understand
um
let's see
Paula asks how do you think kids today
would react if they were suddenly
teleported 40 years into the past
boy
they'd be looking for their phones
and um
what they do instead of phones they
would discover that
um uh
that kids were allowed to do all kinds
of crazy things that nobody allows kids
to do anymore
um and uh uh I think they would um
um
well 40 years ago that's um uh that's
early 80s that's that's modern times
um
I think um
the uh uh
um
you know it's funny when when that
pandemic started
I
was um
I was noticing that suddenly I started
seeing all these people all these
families and so on walking around
outside
and uh uh you know that hadn't been
happening before it's kind of like when
people when sort of there's a change to
the environment and people can't go and
and uh hang out wherever they were
hanging out
um they kind of change and absorb other
kinds of things and my guess is that
that's what the typical kids of of today
transported back to a pre-phone time uh
would end up doing and they would uh uh
40 years ago there were already
VCRs weren't there yes I think so yeah
I think they were
um there was uh most definitely
television and so on to watch
um so I'm not sure that they would have
it it would be too traumatic
um I think they might actually do just
like the people going outside and
walking around
um at the beginning of the pandemic they
might uh just go hang out with more kids
more actual kids in person rather than
only kids on social media
all right maybe one more question here
and then I should um wrap up for today
are
um
Jamie actually asked the questions kind
of interesting have it have aliens
always been referred to as aliens did
they have another name in history
I mean people talked about those
martians for example in the in the time
of War of the Worlds and so on in the um
that was that was a typical kind of name
the concept of the generalized
extraterrestrial intelligence
uh I think the term alieners of quite
recent vintage I think that's not
um
I'm trying to think I mean even
if we think about science fiction
cases
uh
does Star Trek use the term alien
um
you know they talk about you know in the
new life and new civilizations and so on
um
it's interesting now that I think about
it that they say new life and new
civilizations when obviously if they're
discovering civilizations those
civilizations have been around for a
while it's kind of like the discovery of
America so to speak
um it's it's it's a new civilization in
the same sense that America was newly
discovered so to speak but I hadn't
noticed that before but I don't think
that they refer to things as aliens I
think they refer to them as life forms
and so on I don't think in the in that's
the mid-1960s I don't think they were
using that term at that time
um so I don't know exactly when that
um
um when that came into into common use I
think it might not have been until the
80s or even the 1990s
um
let's see
uh
well that's an interesting question from
Jamie have there been any observable
changes to planets during the time
humans have lived on the Earth
yes the red spot of Jupiter has changed
I mean that's a you know the red spot is
a big storm that's been there for 400
years or so but it hasn't been there for
all of human history
but I guess you need a telescope to see
the red spot so that doesn't count there
weren't telescopes until
1605 or six or so
um let's see if things that visible to
the naked eye
uh uh I really doubt it in the time of
human history
um but that's the only one I can think
of but it would need a telescope to to
see it
um and uh
uh yeah that's the only one I can think
of
um
oh yes that's an interesting death is
commenting there's a Catholic history of
discussing ETS that were uh neither
human nor angels
as a theoretical theological field
called EXO theology that's interesting
because I certainly the Catholic church
was not in the 1400s 1500s and so on was
definitely not into the concept of uh
civilizations other than us humans
um so I don't know about more recent
times
um
the uh let's see
um there was a question here which I'm
wondering about which is some
someone asked here uh
um
oh yeah Philip asks what is the oldest
book that you actually use
that is not a museum piece
yeah
I have a whole bunch of antiquarian
books
and I've definitely
looked at them for sort of non-museum
purposes I would say that um
uh
there's certainly books from the 1800s
that I've routinely looked at
um in sort of on a non-museum kind of
way the typical pattern is uh
you know there'll be people like let's
say Isaac Newton where there's a famous
book or two and those famous books will
have been reprinted continuously over
over time but then there are obscure
books that were never reprinted so for
example in the case of Newton uh the you
know famous books like his principia
Mathematica from 1687 reprinted over and
over again you can get you know on the
internet there's a copy of it you can
get uh sort of paperback versions of it
all the time but if you ask about his
chronology of ancient kingdoms which was
the last book he wrote in his life you
know that hasn't been reprinted and I
have a copy of that and although it's
not something in that particular case
that I've particularly referred to have
looked at it
um and that's the thing where probably
in modern times I'm sure the internet
archive for example would have a a
scanned version of that book it's deeply
out of copyright
um but uh that's the thing where it
might be convenient to look at it I mean
for example oh
you know there's certainly books
from I'm trying to think here
like yesterday I looked at a book not
very old 1961 that was uh uh that
actually I would I was wondering you
know I found a copy on on the internet
archive but it was kind of a nuisance to
flip through it all and I'm thinking I
think I have a copy of this book yes I
do okay it's right on my shelf
um
I'm trying to think of other other kinds
of things that um
are of that character I mean as I say
somehow the the minor works of um uh
major figures if you look back at kind
of
I would say
back to probably the 1930s there are
like a bunch of math books and things
like this oh yeah yeah here's an example
I have a pretty complete collection of
the proceedings of the international
Congress and mathematicians which
happens every four years and it's been
happening since the late 1800s I've
absolutely looked at versions of that
from uh
from around 1900 and so on I've looked
at things like the um uh works from
people like Ram nujan from that time on
another one is principia Mathematica of
Whitehead and Russell which is from 1910
or so
um I've certainly uh looked at that I
have um maybe I only have the second
edition of that which might be from 1914
or so
um other things yeah there are a bunch
of books from from the early part of the
20th century that I've absolutely used
for that purpose and I think of older
ones
um
yeah so there are other ones
where
I have certainly been curious about them
and have looked at them I wouldn't
necessarily say I've used them for
reference so to speak
um as I've been working on kind of this
idea of symbolic discourse language it's
kind of way of of representing meaning
without having an explicit human known
human language so to speak more like a
computational language
um there are a bunch of works from the
1600s that uh mostly the ones I've
looked at so far have sort of faced
similarly copies of but some I think I'm
going to have to go back and dive in and
look at the originals because I don't
think that the uh that anybody bothered
to make facsimile copies of them because
people didn't think anybody would would
care about this stuff
uh so I think these these works that are
more on the um uh studying sort of
philosophy and and Linguistics kinds of
things there's probably some older stuff
there that um uh that one you know it's
worth looking at so to speak it's always
an interesting question if you look at
the literature of particular areas of
science what the kind of Decay time is
you know there's some fields of science
like medicine for example where you know
if you're referring to papers that are
more than five years old or something
then people think you're writing stuff
that doesn't make any sense in
mathematics for example there's a bit of
a longer tale people you know you might
refer to something from 100 years ago
and that might be sort of okay
um in physics very unlikely that you'd
be doing that you know physics it's more
like maybe 20 30 years something like
this and different fields have different
difference of Decay times if you're
doing philosophy you might routinely
refer to Plato and that's you know a
2000 year span so to speak so so
different fields have these different
kind of Decay times that a certain
amount of study has been done of
um that uh uh so uh but you know whether
you need the original book
is a question of whether that book I
mean by the time you're getting to
things from Antiquity you're obviously
not going to be looking at the original
book because none of that has survived
and uh anything that has survived is is
sort of a reprinted thing
um and I think the earliest uh I mean
the earliest books I have
come from
maybe I have some from the 1500s
uh
I'm trying to trying to think there yes
um but certainly a bunch from the 1600s
but most of those as I say are not are
no longer kind of incurrency in terms of
um their uh
um uh their their content except maybe
some of these things that relate more to
philosophy and Linguistics and so on
all right well I should probably uh wrap
up there thank you for a bunch of
interesting questions getting me to
think about a bunch of things that um I
don't usually think about so I
appreciate that and um uh I am
uh look forward to
um chatting with you all another time
bye for now